M
MUST REMAIN WITHIN THE
FRAMEWORK OF THE LAW.
QUICKLY ADDING THERE IS A FINE
LINE AND MUCH --
ONE MUST BE VERY CAREFUL.
MELISSA BELL BEGINS OUR
COVERAGE IN KHARKIV, UKRAINE.
MELISSA, WHAT IS THE LATEST
THERE TONIGHT?
>> THE LATEST IS TO THE SOUTH
--
IT APPEARS TO HAVE SLOWED UP
AGAINST THE RUSSIANS FIGHTING
BACK.
ERIN, IT IS HERE IN THE KHARKIV
REGION THAT STREWN MILITARY
QUIT WITH THAT YOU SHOWED THAT
IS THE PRIMARY CONCERN, UKRAINE
SAYING THEY FEAR THAT ALSO THE
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS WHO DIDN'T
MAKE IT BACK ACROSS THE BORDER
MAY STILL BE IN THE REGION.
AND THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT WHAT
ATTACKS THERE MAY BE HERE.
IT IS OF COURSE ABOUT TAKING
CONTROL OF THIS KIND OF REGION,
6000 SQUARE KILOMETERS THAT
HAVE BEEN TAKEN.
MUCH OF THAT'S IN THE KHARKIV
REGION.
AND THEN KEEPING CONTROL OF.
IT AND THEN ALSO, ERIN, TRYING
TO GET HELP TO THOSE PARTS OF
THE COUNTRY THAT HAVE BEEN
LIBERATED.
AND REMEMBER, THAT THERE'S
FEARS, THERE ARE CONCERNS
AMONGST UKRAINIANS ABOUT WHO
MAY HAVE COLLABORATED AND WHO
SIMPLY TRY TO SURVIVE.
>> LARISSA KHARKIV SKY IS
ASHAMED OF WHAT LITTLE SHE.
HAS FOOD, GIVEN BY THE
RUSSIANS.
>> [SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
>> MAINLY, RICE --
AND FLOUR.
--
SHE SAID HER AND HER DAUGHTER
WERE VIRTUALLY PRISONERS OF
THEIR APARTMENT.
TOO AFRAID TO GO OUT.
THE MEDICAL HELP SVETLANA NEEDS
AFTER AN ACCIDENT 15 YEARS AGO,
IMPOSSIBLE TO GET.
>> [SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
>> MOST PEOPLE, SADLER IS, A LU
FLED THROUGH --
ONLY THE POROUS LEFT BEHIND
LIVING ON WHAT THEY CAN GROW,
APPLES AND WATERMELON.
>> [SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
>> THE REST IS EMPTY FRIDGE,
NOW HER PRIMARY CONCERN.
>> [SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
>> SHE'S EMBARRASSED, SHE SAYS,
WE'LL SHOW THE WORLD HOW EMPTY
IT IS.
>> BUT TRIES NONETHELESS TO
OFFER OF SOME OF THE WHAT TO
MEDDLE IN PRESERVE SHE IS JUST
MADE, BEFORE SHOWING US AROUND
THE TIME LIBERATED AFTER
SEVERAL DAYS OF FIGHTING.
THE SHOPS NOW CLOSED WHERE FOR
SIX MONTHS, ONLY AFFORDABLE FOR
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS, SHE SAYS.
>> [INTERPRETER]
THEY MARK PEOPLE, SOMETIMES
THEY KILLED.
THERE WERE SO MANY OF THEM.
AND THEY WERE SO YOUNG.
[END OF TRANSLATION]
>> THE ARRIVAL OF UKRAINIAN
SOLDIERS, RELIEF FOR LARISSA
AND HER FRIEND.
BUT ALMOST TOO MUCH TO DIGEST.
>> THEIR PSYCHOLOGICAL ABUSE.
AND THERE IS VIOLENCE.
FOR ME, PSYCHOLOGICAL ABUSE IS
WORSE.
WE WERE SITTING IN A BASEMENT
FOR TWO DAYS, AND THEN OUR
HUSBANDS CAME AND SAID OUR
SOLDIERS ARE HERE.
[END OF TRANSLATION]
>> IT WAS JUST TEARS OF
HAPPINESS.
>> HAPPINESS AT THE CHANGE OF
HANDS, BUT UNCERTAINTY, STILL,
ABOUT HOW TO SURVIVE AND WHAT
THE IMMEDIATE FUTURE HOLDS.
>> BEAR IN MIND THAT THOSE IN
--
PARTS OF THE COUNTRIES ARE
STILL UNDER THE SUBJECT OF
IMMEDIATE BLACKOUT.
AND WE HAD TO BE VERY CAREFUL
AND WHAT WE CAN SHOW.
THERE WAS A POLICE STATION
RIGHT NEXT DOOR, FOR INSTANCE,
WHERE PEOPLE WERE HAVING THEIR
PHONE CHECKS.
TO SEE WHAT THEY COLLABORATED
OR NOT.
REMEMBER, THIS IS A REGIME, A
POLITICAL REGIME THAT WAS IN
PLACE FOR SIX MONTHS.
AND SO WHAT UKRAINIANS ARE
HAVING TO DEAL WITH IS NOT ONLY
THE FEAR OF RUSSIAN FROM
WITHOUT.
BUT IT NEWFOUND SUSPICION FROM
WITHIN, ERIN.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
TEN DAYS, TRYING TO SWEEP THE
COLLABORATORS.
AND NOW THESE PEOPLE ARE
TREATED --
IT'S THE BEGINNING OF SOMETHING
IN SO MANY WAYS, NOT THE END.
MELISSA, THANK YOU.
I WANT TO GO NOW TO FORMER U.S.
DEFENSE SECRETARY, CHUCK HAZEL.
I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
I WANTED TO START BY GETTING
YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON WHERE WE
STAND.
PEOPLE HERE THIS --
COUNTEROFFENSIVE.
AND THEY HAVE HOPE FOR UKRAINE.
AND LET ME JUST SHOW A MAP FOR
EVERYONE OF WHERE WE ARE.
THE AREA IS IN SOLID YELLOW,
THOSE ARE THE AREAS THAT SAYS
UKRAINE HAS RECOVERED FROM
RUSSIA.
--
IT'S MORE THAN 1000-MILE FRONT.
IT'S A SMALL PORTION.
BUT THE AREA IS IN THE EAST.
SECRETARY, WHAT I WANT TO ASK
YOU IS, RUSSIA SAYS IT WAS
OUTMANNED IN THE COUNTER
OFFENSIVE BY UKRAINE 8 TO 1.
A SENIOR RUSSIAN OFFICIAL SAYS.
THAT THAT'S HUGELY SIGNIFICANT
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY, OVERALL,
COMING INTO THE WORLD, UKRAINE
HAD FEWER THAN 200,000 ACTIVE
DUTY FORCES.
RUSSIA HAD NEARLY ONE.
MILLION TO OUTNUMBER RUSSIA
EIGHT TO, ONE UKRAINE HAD TO
HAVE USED A --
LOT OF FORCES FROM SOMEWHERE
ELSE INTO THIS REGION.
THEY CAN'T SUSTAIN THIS
INDEFINITELY.
SO WITH THAT PERSPECTIVE, WHAT
DO YOU THINK?
IT WILL UKRAINE BE ABLE TO HOLD
THESE GAINS AND CONTINUE THIS
COUNTEROFFENSIVE ELSEWHERE?
>> WELL, THANKS, ERIN.
WE DON'T KNOW.
THERE ARE TWO BIG DYNAMICS HERE
AMONG MANY DYNAMICS.
WILL PLAY OUT AND ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION.
ONE IS, HOW THE RUSSIANS WILL
RESPOND TO THIS.
WHAT HAS JUST HAPPENED TO THEM.
I, MEAN PUTIN STARTED THIS WAR.
PUTIN CAN AFFORD TO LOSE THIS
WAR.
AND YOU MENTIONED SOME OF THE
REASONS WHY.
INTERNAL PROBLEMS IN RUSSIA.
OTHER REASONS, MORE SIGNIFICANT
THAN THAT.
THE SECOND PART OF THIS IS YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT THE UKRAINIANS
MOVE TROOPS INTO THIS AREA SO
THAT THEY HAD THE ABILITY FOR
THE BLITZ --
I SUSPECT THAT THEY DID.
THEY HAD TO MOVE SOME TROOPS.
WHERE THEY TOOK THOSE TROOPS
FROM, I DON'T KNOW.
BUT THIS WOULD HAVE BEEN A
STRATEGIC ISSUE AND CALCULATION
THAT THEY MADE THAT IT WAS
WHATEVER THEY HAD TO DO, IT WAS
WORTH IT.
THEY ALSO WOULD'VE HAD GOOD
INTELLIGENT TO SHOW THE
RUSSIANS WERE WEAK IN THIS
AREA.
LOGISTICS HAVE ALWAYS BEEN A
PROBLEM FOR THE RUSSIANS HERE
IN THE LAST SEVEN MONTHS.
AND THEY CONTINUE TO BE A
PROBLEM.
>> YOU ARE SERVING AS DEFENSE
SECRETARY WHEN RUSSIA INVADED
AND ANNEXED CRIMEA IN 2014.
AND NOW --
THE COMMANDER OF UKRAINIAN
FORCES HAS TAKEN CREDIT FOR THE
MISSILE ATTACK THAT TOOK OUT
THE RUSSIAN AIR FORCE, THE
RUSSIAN PLANES THERE.
HE SAID THERE'S GONNA BE A LOT
WHERE THAT CAME FROM.
SAYING THAT IS THE AMBITION.
TO GO THAT FAR TO RETAKE
CRIMEA.
DO YOU THINK UKRAINE CAN PULL
OFF A FULL VICTORY AS DEFINED
BY CRIMEA IS BACK IN UKRAINE?
>> WELL, I THINK, AGAIN, IT'S
AN UNANSWERED QUESTION.
I THINK WHAT THE UKRAINIANS ARE
DOING, AND FROM WHAT I HAVE
SEEN, AND MAYBE I HAVE A LITTLE
BETTER EDUCATED UNDERSTANDING
OF ALL THIS THAN MANY.
I DON'T HAVE THE SPECIFICS OF
THE INTELLIGENCE.
I HAVEN'T SEEN IT.
BUT, WHAT THEY ARE DOING WITH
WHAT THEY'VE GOT AND WHAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE THEM, AND
THE SOPHISTICATION OF OUR
WEAPONRY HAS GOTTEN BETTER THAT
WE'VE GIVEN THEM.
PLUS OUR INTELLIGENCE IS BETTER
THAT WE ARE WORKING WITH THEM
ON.
AND THE UK